the jogan experience when did you
realize that you had that kind of crazy
power cuz it's kind of funny that a guy
who started out grappling and didn't do
any sparring at all for his first four
MMA fights was one of the most dangerous
Strikers in the sport um I don't know I
mean I grew up playing baseball and
threw really hard and then you know when
I when I started and not sparring
started MMA you know I'd hit the P or
you know Focus Ms and and everybody' say
oh [__] you hit hard it's just natural
but yeah so I guess it just took me a
while to figure out where to put it
there's a few I think gy I think
takanori gy started out as a pitcher
which makes sense you see the way that
guy throws punches just [__] whips
his whole body into it like a fast ball
put a lot of weight into it yeah it's
that's a actually probably a great thing
to start out with just to learn how to
put a lot of force behind your arm
driving with your legs and everything
yeah completely makes sense if you think
about it cuz you think about how many
guys practice with medicine balls now
you know they whip medicine balls
against the wall to advance your
punching
power yeah it's hard to teach I mean
yeah you either have power or you don't
have power yeah I mean you can
definitely get better at mechanics to
make it harder mhm but not not like what
a lot of guys have naturally right isn't
it Wild that's a crazy thing because you
can't really tell sometimes by looking
at guys like there's guys that just look
well you look pretty strong but there's
some guys like uh they just don't look
like they carry that much power but they
have crazy power right it's it's a it's
weird power is a weird thing no I agree
like you either have nuclear power or
you don't you know but and again I think
a lot of that is it is mechanics but a
lot of the most mechanics come naturally
like some of those
you know pitchers that that can throw
the ball so goddamn fast yeah and some
of them are skinny as [__] you how the
hell that you know they
just whip that thing around and then
there's also your frame you know like
some guys just have bigger shoulders
bigger hands they're just naturally
designed to hit things more more
leverage points yeah it's uh it's just
when you think back like as a Pioneer in
the sport I mean it's pretty wild what
you guys did pretty wild that you
entered into the sport that at the time
it was just kind of a way to make some
money right it wasn't there was I mean
when I started uh doing the postf fight
interviews it was banned from cable the
only way you could get it was direct TV
I actually got Direct TV when
specifically yeah 97 cuz it was uh I
feel like it was right after it wasn't
banned from cable
yet until after I fought
on7 one of those one of those years it
was banned from cable and there was a
lot of shenanigans with like Budweiser
and you remember like McCain McCain was
trying to keep it out yeah for sure
calling it human [__] fighting yeah yeah
I wasn't a fan of his no most MMA guys
weren't because it was so ridiculous
there was no deaths in MMA to speak of
right not like in MMA in boxing which we
have you know few every year right and
they were trying to say it was more
dangerous I'm like I don't think it is I
don't think it is I mean they're all
everything's D even Combat Sports
dangerous but to say that MMA is more D
it's just ignorance he just didn't
understand what was happening no yeah it
uh I I have heard that over the years a
lot of different things and yeah I got
nothing bad to say about MMA I mean I
grew up as a wrestler and you know kind
of competing what I've done my whole
life and and you know I I don't feel
like it affected me in a bad way at all
you know if anything it was positive
things that made me tougher made me you
know have more drive and with other
things in my life well you're very
fortunate that you came out of it on the
other end you know healthy yeah we we
know guys who haven't you know right no
I know there's a few guys that are
pretty I'm not saying that it hasn't
affected some guys but yeah I'm just
saying unfortunately I I went through it
fairly good no you went through it great
and I think a lot of it was and ry's the
same way just being smart in training a
lot of these guys
just bang way too much in practice Yeah
you know and I'm always a advocate of
sometimes not all the time but sometimes
in training if you're training to fight
you have to fight in training yeah and
how do you know how to manage that yeah
I think over the years you know you just
you definitely have one we have one Hard
Solid Spar day a
week uh and then more technical sparring
uh another day with the big gloves on
and then uh the other days of the MMA
gloves you know we're we're still going
hard but not with the Striking part just
lighter
strikes which you know it's kind of hard
sometimes some of these guys when they
go lighter that they're you know they
slow down their punches instead of you
know keeping your speed there and your
timing
and just touching each other and not
punching is hard so that's kind of a
hard thing to to get used to and it took
me a while to to have that control I
would accidentally drop guys a lot in
practice because I didn't have control
when I was you know kind of new to the
sport is there a way that you do now
where you train guys to learn how to
punch fast but not hit hard yeah you
yell at them you know that's it don't do
it in slow motion you know yeah don't do
it in slow motion but also don't connect
you don't need to hit hard but yeah
don't go slow you know yeah you just got
to remind them cuz guys just do it
naturally well it's kind of crazy for
you as a Pioneer because you guys had to
kind of figure it out makes me feel a
Pioneer I hear it all the time what's a
good word I don't know but yeah that is
a good word but does make me feel old
you're the definition of a Pioneer I
mean UFC 17 I mean come on man that's uh
that was back in the dark days feel like
I should have a [__] Panda do some
gold
head on [__] yeah yeah but I mean
there's no better word for it but back
then you guys had to kind of learn along
the way and the as the sport evolved
I've always said this that there's not a
sport that you could ever point to that
has evolved more since
1993 to 2023 oh no it's nothing even
close you watch fights today like the
makev volkanovski fight I mean
everything's so high level now
everyone's so good in every aspect of
the game yeah that was a good I mean
their first one was a good one that was
a I didn't expect that I didn't expect
it either yeah that guy evolved he got
better he got better and he he figured
out a lot of the things that he was
doing wrong in that fight and then
setting up that head kick with those
body I thought vul was gonna get him
this I just felt like he had more tools
MH and easier adjustments did you ever
have to take a fight like that on 10
days notice cuz that's what's crazy
about it took it so short notice yeah a
number of times especially in Pride that
was pretty common yeah Pride they would
just call you up like a week before the
fight right I fought big nog for he was
heavyweight champ at the time and 10
days
notice Jesus
um yeah I mean there was there was a
couple other there was I fought uh bo
Deonte on probably a week's notice so
when during the pride days two and a
half months after a knee surgery a new
ACL surgery no
way they called me up and I was haunted
out in Colorado and they tracked me down
on my buddy's cell phone up in the
mountains and said hey you need to and I
didn't have a contract at the time and I
went and had knee surgery CU I tore my
knee and and uh he's like well if you
don't take the fight we don't know
what'll happen with any future contracts
so I'm like all right I'll do it but
you're paying me win or lose you know
the the win bonus also and so I I took
the fight
luckily I knocked him out real quick
with that
knee so
yeah